bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 16 février les grandes manoeuvres
dans le monde de la chasse avant
l'ouverture des débats parlementaires
sur le projet de loi adopté en conseil
des ministres aujourd'hui sur le lobby
des chasseurs sur les financements de
ces et du lean proposeront deux ans
l'augmentation du nombre de
contribuables et de foyers imposables
enfants 199 signes de croissance que
noms de personnes exonérées à diminuer
les saumons génétiquement modifiée
pourrait très prochainement être vendus
sur le marché américain les grands
accords internationaux sur ce sujet
semble dépasser la voix du net
permettent aussi de faire ses courses et
ses achats bien au chaud chez soi
le commerce en ligne est en pleine
explosion
le seul nom publier un nouvel album une
équipe de france 2 l'a rencontré chez
lui à dakar les chasseurs sachant que la
chasse est une chausse trappes pour ceux
qui vont à la pêche ou à la chasse
électorale attendait la loi sur la
chasse annoncées par le gouvernement
fournissant déjà leur défense le conseil
des ministres a adopté un texte sur les
périodes de chasse la chasse de nuit le
jour de nos chastes tout cela parce
qu'il faut désormais mettre en
conformité les textes français avec ceux
définis au nom de l'union européenne
avant même l'ouverture d'un débat
parlementaire qui promet chasseurs et
agriculteurs ont prévu des amendes
commentaires sur le texte de la loi
et puis sur les réactions avec arnaud
bouteille daniel licht premier
changement le projet de loi ne fixe pas
de date pour les périodes de chasse mais
il impose des conditions pour les
oiseaux migrateurs la chasse deviendrait
interdite pendant les périodes de
migration et de reproduction comme
l'exigent une directive européenne
le ministre de l'environnement et les
préfets fixerait alors les dates
d'ouverture et de fermeture selon l'état
de conservation des espèces la chasse de
nuit serait autorisé sous certaines
conditions
cela concerne le gibier d'eau dans les
départements où cette pratique relève de
la tradition locale
les chasseurs dénoncent une
discrimination
ou bien on reconnais que la chasse de
nuit est quelque chose de traditionnel
du culturel
on le reconnaît plus prompt pour tous
les départements c'est-à-dire que ceux
qui traditionnellement chasse
aujourd'hui comme ça et incarne le alors
la corde 42 ou à la corde à personne le
texte définit un droit de non chasse aux
propriétaires de terrains il pourrait
interdire aux chasseurs de pénétrer chez
eux
en revanche les dégâts commis par les
animaux sauvages vivant sur leur terrain
serait alors frais enfin le mercredi
deviendrait un jour sans chasse pour
éviter tout accident avec les enfants
une condition qui exigent et les non
chasseurs pour le gouvernement la
fenêtre de tir est très réduite alors
ils tentent de viser juste pour ne
blesser ni les écologistes ni les
porteurs de fusils
j'ai souhaité proposer un texte global
un texte qui constitue effectivement un
compromis demandant des efforts et aux
chasseurs et aux noms chanteur donc
susceptible de rétablir les après les
chasseurs la droite et quelques députés
de la majorité rejette déjà ce texte
le débat prévu fin mars à l'assemblée
s'annonce explosif
c'est à dire que la france est le
premier pays de l'union européenne pour
le nombre de chasseurs 1500000
détiennent un permis valide et et ses
chasseurs sont très bien organisés leur
réussite électorale lors des dernières
élections européennes l'a démontré il y
à 150 députés regroupés dans un groupe
d'étude parlementaire pro chasseurs la
droite et la gauche sont donc très
attention dans certains départements à
coller au plus près aux intérêts le
coucher du boisserie et claude dernier
dans le département des pyrénées
orientales ont pu constater l'action de
lobbying d'un représentant du mouvement
chasse pêche nature et tradition alain
esclopé le sait que l'on aille à la
chasse ou qu'on parte en politique il ne
vaut jamais rentrés bredouilles
cet après midi là le député européen
cpnt et président de la fédération des
chasseurs a rendez vous avec le
député-maire ps de céret objectif
avancer ses contre-propositions au
projet de loi sur la chasse
les deux hommes se connaissent bien ils
militaient autrefois tous les deux au
parti socialiste et ne dédaigne pas se
retrouver pour une partie de chasse
le ton est au consensus donnait raison
et donc quand le chauffeur pour les
hommes ce qu'il veut s'il est ce que
monsieur sicre a réussi son oral nous
c'est l'écrit qui nous intéresse
de tels rendez-vous alain esclopé en a
pris avec tous les parlementaires du
département
et si les chasseurs ont de tout temps
été reçus par les élus ils le sont
aujourd'hui avec célérité qu'ils le
fassent tête rapport d'autant plus qu'à
eu les élections européennes bon jeu
propre ça serait fallu vingt ridicule de
ballons est sûr que l'on est sûr que non
ah mais ça mais j'en que c'est comme ça
sinon sinon ce serait nier la valeur
démocratique de la vente dans le
languedoc roussillon les verts observe
la situation à la loupe tous les jours
maryse arditi et peluches la presse
régionale
elle non plus n'est pas dupe sur
l'intérêt porté aux chasseurs basquiat
nom d'un député ps a fait un effort pour
donner un gage le gage que lui pouvait
donner aux chasseurs en disant je fais m
l'aude dans les départements on pourra
chasser la nuit alors qu'elle n'était
pas redevenir chacun donne la caution
qui peut les chasseurs c'est un lobby
selon vous dans cette région plutôt ici
je ne sens pas comme tel mais vous savez
chaque fois qu'il y a un look conte
social qui connaît quelques difficultés
nous sommes la preuve et de lettres
circulaire de pétition nous sommes
habitués à travailler sur des formes
dépression cette approche pragmatique
n'empêche pas henri sicre d'être
réaliste quand on lui demande comment il
envisage les débats à venir à
l'assemblée nationale il répond d'une
phrase ça va chauffer problème pour les
chasseurs la justice la cour des comptes
s'intéresse de très près aux
financements croisés entre les
fédérations de chasse organismes publics
et le mouvement politique cpnt chasse
pêche nature et tradition présidée par
jean saint-josse une question parmi
d'autres pour les enquêteurs comment la
grande manifestation 98 at elle été
organisées financièrement en cap david
bazié vincent dubroca 14 février 81,18
les chasseurs font une démonstration de
force à l'appel de l'union des
fédérations de chasse cet organisme
public a dépensé 30 millions de francs
pour acheminer les manifestants
pour la cour des comptes c'est de
l'argent public au service des thèses
d'un parti politique
jacques lapeyre et le trésorier de
chasse pêche nature traditions il réfute
elle était organisée par l'union avait
des circulaires bien précises où ils
nous on nous disait attention qu'il n'y
ait pas de slogans à caractère politique
s'était strictement interdite où il n'ya
pas de banderole avait des propos
diffamatoires en vue de oi l'encontre de
mara mots voilés par exemple mais les
banderoles brandies ce jour-là embête
fortement les dirigeants de cpnt des
plaintes pourraient être déposées
pour l'heure le srpj de bordeaux enquête
sur le passé de cpnt andré gusta
l'ancien président et fondateur du
mouvement est mise en examen pour avoir
utilisé des salariés de la fédération
des chasseurs de dordogne au profit de
cpnt
c'est tout à fait modeste puisque nous
n'avons pas les moyens financiers de
faire campagne européenne de 99 avec
jean saint-josse la nouvelle équipe
dirigeante opte pour une plus grande
rigueur financière
mais pour les associations écologistes
il y a toujours collusion avec les
fédérations de chasse cpnt n'existe que
par les fédérations départementales des
chasseurs
c'est le parti des présidents de
fédérations de chasse et rien d'autre
toutes les élections on voit très bien
que sont les présidents qui conduisent
les listes l'argent de la chasse est un
milliard et demi de francs par an de
cotisation obligatoire collectées par
les fédérations henri sabarot et lui ces
peines
et le président de la riche fédération
de gironde qui vient d'acheter ce vaste
domaine
la propriété est délimité par les et que
l'on voit tout le tour cela fait environ
80 hectares en ardèche la fédération
vient de s'offrir un col de montagne
dans les pyrénées atlantiques encore un
nouveau siège signes extérieurs de
richesse la cour des comptes dénonce les
cagnottes constitué avec des surplus
financier qui doivent être reversés à
l'office national de la chasse
il suffisait que la tutelle nous
demandent de rendre cet argent et nous
l'aurions fait
si l'état n'exerce pas son contrôle
c'est peut-être que derrière chaque
chasseur il y à un électeur comme ça va
bien mieux pour la croissance le nombre
de foyers français qui ont acquitter
l'impôt sur le revenu en 99 à augmenter
52 5% du total des contribuables
français payent cet impôt symbolique
dont la réforme est régulièrement
envisagée même si l'on parle beaucoup
plus en ce moment de la taxe
d'habitation et d'autres aménagements
fiscaux
reportage nathalie moisan et illzach
vous ne l'avez pas reçu pas de panique
la feuille verte arrive en deux vagues
la première est parti hier et vous avez
jusqu'au 15 mars pour la renvoyer
mais si mais si vous êtes plus en plus
nombreux à payer l'impôt sur le revenu 8
% de contribuables en plus l'an dernier
la faute à la reprise économique et au
chômage qui diminue au total 52 % des
foyers fiscaux ont payé cet impôt soit
16 millions de foyers 1 1 pour qui
représente 17 % des recettes fiscales de
l'état
bien loin derrière la tva partout en
europe la part de cet impôt dans les
prélèvements obligatoires est plus
importante que chez nous 23 % en
allemagne 53 même au danemark
cette année neuf de ces pays prévoient
de faire baisser l'impôt sur le revenu à
commencer par nos voisins d'outre-rhin
l'allemagne monsieur coderre via
d'annoncer une baisse des impôts très
importante sur plusieurs années qui va
se traduire en particulier par une
baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu bon et
on conçoit bien que la france dans ce
contexte de monnaie unique et de
concurrence fiscale tous azimuts la
france peut pas rester à l'écart de ce
que font les autres
une réforme qui serait évidemment
populaire
à l'impôt sur le revenu est souvent
perçu comme trop lourd et injuste on lui
reproche sa trop grande concentration
sur les classes moyennes
du coup s'il veut satisfaire un plus
grand nombre le gouvernement a tout
intérêt à s'attaquer d'abord un impôt
comme la taxe d'habitation qui touche
tout le monde
des milliers de manifestants aujourd'hui
dans les rues de montpellier pour
réclamer la création de postes
d'enseignants dans les écoles
maternelles et élémentaires les
enseignants de l'hérault sont en grève
depuis le 7 février c'est le cas
également
l'instituteur de parents d'élèves du
gard qui protestent depuis le mois de
janvier contre la carte scolaire
envisagée par le ministère et un déficit
de création de poste estime t-il la
chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation vient de rejeter les pourvois
de roland dumas de christine deviers
joncour qui contestait la régularité des
procédures engagées contre depuis 1997
les juges d'instruction eva joly et
laurence vichnievsky ont donc désormais
toute liberté pour renvoyer monsieur
dumas et madame deviers joncour en
correctionnelle le juge d'instruction
gilberte il vient d'ordonner le renvoi
devant la cour d'assises de paris du
tueur en série présumé
guy georges soupçonnait d'avoir
assassiné sept personnes agressées
quatre autres s'étaient entre 91 à 97
dans l'est parisien
pour france 2 valérie fourni ou rémy
poissonnier didier rancoeurs ont obtenu
témoignage du juge yves bertil et
évoquer avec lui la nécessité d'un
fichier spécialisé recensant les
personnes auteurs d'agressions sexuelles
si ce fichier avait existé
peut-être peut-être certains crimes de
guy georges aurait-il été évité celle
affaire qui a bouleversé sa carrière
l'affairé guy georges qui en plus jugé
verte il la ferdi georges et c'est raté
le 26 mars 1998
le tueur de l'est parisien est enfin
arrêté et conduit dans le bureau du juge
t-il
ce jour là ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'il est convoqué à la brigade
criminelle
déjà en septembre 1995 il est arrêté et
condamné pour violence avec arme
c'est à cette occasion que les policiers
m'ont prélever son empreinte génétique
l'adn il a alors déjà tué cinq jeunes
femmes à paris mais aucun recoupement
n'a pu être fait deux ans plus tard il
faudra attendre que guy georges tuer à
nouveau deux fois pour le confondre
grâce à son empreinte génétique il est
tout à fait évident que ces affiches et
génétique a été testé à l'époque il
aurait été identifié dès 1984 à dire qu
il ya eu beaucoup de morts d'éviter lui
rue deux victimes
et il s'agit des stèles mag et de magali
cirrhotiques 19 ans violée et assassinée
chez elle en septembre 1995
si en 95 on avait eu cette famille le
fameux accès aux officier
la police avait seul accès au fichier
guy georges n'aurait pas fait ninaute
fille n'y restait nimaga ligne et elles
ne seraient tués c'est en juin 98 à
peine quatre mois après l'arrestation de
guy georges que le législateur décide la
création d'un fichier génétique un
fichier qui ne concerne que les
criminels sexuels
déjà condamné les jusqu'à tard a fait
preuve d'une certaine frilosité d'abord
dans le champ d'application de ce
fichier
vous n'ignorez pas que ce fichier est
uniquement conçu pour un champ
d'application restreint où une seule
infraction à caractère sexuel ça veut
dire que pour tout ce qui touche au
terrorisme tout ce qui touche aux vols à
main armée ou même aux meurtres et
assassinats non connotée sexuellement ce
fichier sera purement et simplement
impraticable pour les professionnels un
an et demi après le fichier génétique
n'existe toujours pas guy georges lui a
été jugée entièrement responsable de ses
actes il est renvoyé devant la cour
d'assises
dans l'aveyron à flavin les enquêteurs
poursuivent leurs investigations après
le double meurtre commis lundi matin la
disparition d'un nourrisson d'un mois
une information judiciaire pour meurtre
et enlèvement a été ouverte
le mari et père des victimes été remis
en liberté après avoir été longuement
interrogé par les gens d'un le pompage
de l'épave du pétrolier erika qui a
coulé le 12 décembre dernier au large du
sud finistère pourrait débuter à la fin
du mois d'avril sur la sécurité du
transformant été mis hier le premier
ministre annonçait plusieurs
propositions de la france au niveau
européen et international monsieur
jospin demande l'interdiction des
navires à simple coque d'ici 2008
cependant les pétroliers qui bénéficient
eux d'une double coque ne sont pas non
plus à l'abri de graves incidents les
contrôles faits sur ces bateaux le
démontre
voyez le reportage de jean marie n'est
emmanuel bec dans le monde un pétrolier
sur cinq est équipé d'une double coque
un progrès qui selon certains experts
limiterait les risques de marée noire la
double coque créer un espace l'art de
deux mètres destinées à amortir les
chocs mais pour d'autres spécialistes
cette innovation peut transformer les
tankers en véritable bombe durant une
pression d'eau qui va remonter qui va
jouer sur l'air avec des poches de gaz
donc on a tout pour que ça soit
véritablement explosif et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé en 1992 au
large du port de la corogne après
l'échouage de la gêne si l'un des tout
premiers double coque
il existe pourtant aujourd'hui une
alternative une troisième génération de
bateaux et navires dit à pau
intermédiaire double coque large de six
mètres et surtout un double pont qui
permet car il ne sera pas déchirer en
cas de choc d'évacuer le pétrole dans
des zones non touchées
alain gry il fut le promoteur de ce
prototype auquel ont participé plusieurs
pays et constructeurs européens projets
beaucoup trop cher pour les armateurs
toute sécurité a un prix
plus de sécurité ça devrait entraîner
des taux de fret supérieur puisque du
point de vue de l'affréteur du point de
vue des assureurs du point de vue des
risques potentiels le navire sera mieux
protégé que le navire précédent
américain qui lui même était bien mieux
protégés que les navires ordinaire à
simple coque
depuis dix ans les américains ont opté
pour le pétrolier double coque à son
tour la france vient de demander aux
pétroliers de ne plus affrété d'ici 2008
que ce type de navire la pollution du
danube et de son bassin au cyanure sous
touche désormais l'ukraine près la
roumanie les usa via la hongrie
pollution faible disent les autorités
ukrainiennes ce soir l'engrais attribue
la responsabilité de la pollution au
propriétaire du complexe minier roumat
c'est à dire en partie à une compagnie
australienne qui bien sûr réfute toutes
ces critiques d'ailleurs les analyses
faites aujourd'hui en roumanie démontre
que petit à petit le cyanure s'est
diluée dans les eaux et pour autant et
il s'agit bien d'une catastrophe
écologique
comme le rapportent nos envoyés spéciaux
en roumanie hélène béring et andrei sera
depuis la nuit de l'accident le 30
janvier
ces biologistes de la région de baia
mare et sont sur le pied de guerre
toutes les deux heures les eaux des
rivières sommet celle à push touché par
le cyanure sont analysés et les premiers
résultats officiels annoncés aujourd'hui
prouve la gravité de la pollution les
premiers résultats nous les avons pris
le 31 janvier les taux était de 13,2
millions g de ses murs par jaguar 13,26
mg par litre soit plus de mille fois le
taux maximum autorisé en roumanie
ces analyses sans appel constitue la
première preuve de la responsabilité de
l'exploitant
malgré ces nouveaux résultats le
directeur australien dao rôle rejette en
bloc les accusations et réaffirme la
très grande fiabilité de son entreprise
selon lui le site a toujours respecté
les normes les plus élevées de
protection de l'environnement
pour l'instant aucun lien n'a été établi
entre la fuite du cyanure et la
mortalité des poissons
12e causes peuvent expliquer cette
mortalité comme l'absence d'oxygène dans
l'eau en raison de la glace qui recouvre
les rivières ces explications à
paraissent peu crédibles et isole la
direction de la compagnie australienne
obligeant les autorités régionales à
prendre leurs distances
d'ailleurs les experts spécialistes ne
peuvent pas se prononcer sur les mesures
de sécurité de l'entreprise
nous pourrons décider de la fermeture
définitive de cette société dès le
lendemain de l'accident l'état roumain
obligé la société à o bull a cessé ses
activités les autorités régionales ont
déjà engagé des discussions avec
l'entreprise australienne
il ne fait plus aucun doute qu'en cas de
culpabilité de l'exploitant la région de
baia mare et réclamera des dommages et
intérêts en allemagne le parti
chrétien-démocrate la cité ou n'en finit
pas de régler ses comptes intérieure
après la découverte d'un financement
plus que douteux de son passé électorale
sous la direction d'helmut kohl son
successeur la tête de la cdo wolfgang
schauble vient de démissionner victimes
des effets du scandale d'un don illégal
d'un million de marks à son parti berlin
correspondance d'olivier werner la
pression était trop forte à l'intérieur
du parti
victime d'un putsch en quelque sorte
wolfgang schaeuble
il jette l'épongé la mort dans l'âme il
abandonne ses deux casquettes président
de l'acq cd ou président du groupe
parlementaire et il semble manquer de
souffle avant d'annoncer sa retraite
définitive de la vie politique je me
retire
et je ne suis plus candidat arrive après
helmut kohl wolfgang chef breton pour
avoir trempé dans le système des caisses
noires
une sortie par la petite porte mais
surprise aussitôt revenu dans
l'hémicycle
le chancelier s'est approché du
démissionnaire pour lui glisser un mot
de réconfort
un geste fort spontanée peut-être
apprécié en tout cas partout les
parlementaires
j'ai voulu serrer la main de monsieur
charles ble parce que je le vois comme
un adversaire pas comme un ennemi
la franchit une étape importante et
difficile aujourd'hui et je lui ai
souhaité bon courage
du courage il en faudra en effet à
wolfgantzen bleus pour expliquer devant
ses juges la pratique des pots-de-vin il
laisse la td ou dans un piteux état
la facture risque d'être très lourde à
porter pour les chrétiens-démocrates
lattes cd ou est d'ores et déjà condamné
à rembourser 140 millions de francs et
il ne s'agit là que d'un premier
redressement selon certains experts
l'amande au total pourrait atteindre un
milliard de francs alors ce serait la
ruine pure et simple de la droite
allemande
la paix est en panne en irlande le
gouvernement autonome de la province
étant suspendu par londres le dirigeant
républicain oui ici à droite de l'écran
thierry adam s'est déclaré aujourd'hui
qu'il pouvait y avoir de réexamen du
processus de paix nous n'avons aucune
marge de manoeuvre dans cette situation
fin de citation des propos de ce
monsieur gerry adams
à l'origine il ya je le rappelle le
choix de l'armée républicaine irlandaise
l'ira de ne pas accepter de rendre ses
armes et à des alertes au kosovo la
force multinationale de paix impose
maintenant un couvre-feu craignant
d'autres explosions de violences comme
celles connues ce dernier week-end
mitrovic à nos envoyés spéciaux à nos
consignes et gilles jacquet ont
accompagné une patrouille de la force de
paix dans cette ville de mitrovica puis
se sont rendus dans un hôpital une sorte
de journée ordinaire avec toutes les
tensions entre communautés de 18h à 6h
du matin nul n'est censé circuler dans
mitrovica
chaque nuit les chars et les patrouilles
à pied promènent leurs faisceaux
lumineux le long des rues désertes
un couvre-feu exceptionnel pour une
situation exceptionnellement tendu
il a suffi cet après midi qu'un
cameraman albanais de la télévision
théoriquement multi ethnique du kosovo
s'aventure du côté serbe de la ville
pour provoquer une brève échauffourée le
cameraman et tousser dans les chevaux de
frise et seule l'intervention des
policiers des nations unies et de serbes
plus modérée permettra de calmer la
situation de plus en plus et malgré les
efforts de la mission kouchner il y a
deux villes dans la ville de mitrovica
on a espéré un temps que le kosovo
multiethnique intérêts martyrs dix ans
de l'hôpital de mitrovica la mission
kouchner avait repris la gestion de cet
hôpital serbe et ré embaucher du
personnel albanais mais le drapeau de
l'onu ne flotte plus sur le bâtiment
seul le drapeau serbe est à la fiche car
après des mois de négociations l'onu a
estimé qu'il était impossible de faire
travailler ensemble les deux communautés
aujourd'hui le personnel serve de
l'hôpital estime qu'une séparation est
nécessaire on les a pas laissé entrer on
s'est opposé à ce projet mais installé
et c'est là qu'on est encore ici au nord
du kosovo y aller pour le seul hôpital
du kosovo où des médecins serbes
travaillent et dépassons servent ils
peuvent se soigner tous les jours
résultat les médecins marocains de la
kfor qui devait renforcer cet hôpital
multi élus sont allés s'installer
ailleurs
ils ont monté leur salle de consultation
leurs échographies leur bloc opératoire
dans une ancienne usine de batteries
sauf cette semaine et simplement s'est
brutalement on savait pas cet hôpital
marocain est installé du côté sud de la
ville du côté albanais ou précédemment
il n'y avait pas d'hôpital avec les
moyens que nous avons amené une zone
moins bien sûr d'ouvrir une structure
hospitalière pour faire face aux besoins
urgents de la population
albanaise qui se retrouver son support
hospitalier depuis l'échec de l'hôpital
multiethnique d'autres programmes moins
ambitieux ont été mis en place pour
tenter de maintenir un minimum de
coexistence entre serbes et albanais
mais bon séjour d'un couvre-feu
c'est la logique de maintien de la paix
qui l'emportent ce qui consiste
essentiellement à maintenir une bonne
distance entre les deux communautés
il ya une quinzaine de jours à montréal
une entente internationale semblait se
dessiner sur la biosécurité il
s'agissait d'empêcher toute modification
manipulations génétiques pouvant
entraîner de graves conséquences pour la
santé des consommateurs un reportage de
la chaîne américaine cbs vient de tout
démentir et vient de faire état d'une
manipulation génétique sur des saumons
débouchant sur la production de ces
poissons modifié explications louis
carzou ceci n'est pas un seul mot en
tout cas pas seulement car ces poissons
ont été génétiquement modifiés à l'aide
d'autres espèces dans le seul but de les
faire grossir plus vite des saumons mais
aussi des truites qui font la fierté
d'aef protéines une société de chicago
dont l'ambition est d'être la première à
commercialiser des animaux génétiquement
modifiés
c'est une entreprise américaine qui a
des succursales au canada il ya beaucoup
d'expérience qui sont faites sur le
saumon canadiens ont fait du saut
montrant gêné pour qui grossissent plus
vite
or on a de plus en plus d'éléments qui
montrent que des ces poissons ont été
par exemple donné à consommer à une
partie de la population canadienne sans
aucune autorisation simplement pour
avancer les tests je dirais de goût
avant de rejoindre les bacs des
supermarchés ces saumons de laboratoires
doivent subir une série de tests en
données par les autorités sanitaires
américaines
mais la procédure est déjà contestée
l'administration les considère comme des
médicaments pas comme des aliments
c'est une grosse erreur car les tests
pour les médicaments sont secrets et
surtout conduit sur une période beaucoup
trop court et pour les manifestants
réunis devant le siège de f protéines
l'autre danger est de voir ces poissons
de l'an 2000 s'échapper de leurs lieux
d'élevage et ceux dispersés dans la
nature
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de systèmes
d'aquaculture qu'ils soient complètement
étanche du milieu environnement et des
études ont montré récemment que une
quantité extrêmement faible de poissons
transgéniques pouvait conduire à l'est
sanctions rapides des variétés de
poissons sauvages ses premiers poissons
transgéniques fragilise déjà la corde
montréal sur les ogm signé il ya
seulement quinze jours
mais il est vrai qu'avec ces saumons là
c'est le profit qui vient en mangeant la
coopérative des monts de joux procède
actuellement au retrait du marché d'un
lot de fromage mondor princ un contrôle
réalisé au stade de la fabrication unis
en évidence la présence de listeria
monocytogenes alors sont concernés les
marques monde jouée qu'au des forêts
vanier la gélinotte avec des dates
limites de consommation pouvant être des
13 14 15 mars 2000
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu suite
d'incidents de consommation mais la
coopérative demande aux personnes qui
détiendraient ces produits de ne pas les
consommer et de les détruire je vous
donne un numéro de téléphone pour
éventuellement vous renseigner à propos
de ce retrait d'un marché des lots de
grandeur et de non de jousse et le 03 80
89 81 02 vous retrouverez tout cela sur
l'adresse internet de france 2 et puis
la préfecture de l'isère vient
d'annoncer le décès d'un homme de 63 ans
habitant de l'isle d'abeau
cet homme est mort à l'hôpital
neurologique de lyon bron et selon la
préfecture
il existe une suspicion de maladie de
creutzfeldt-jakob maladie dérivé de la
maladie de la vache folle de fusions en
rachats d'absorption en alliance les
modifications dans le monde des affaires
de la communication sont de plus en plus
nombreuses les voix de l'internet semble
très appétissante
le groupe lagardère vient en quelque
sorte de pratiquer un échange qualifié
d'extraordinaire avec le groupe allemand
de télécommunications deutsche telekom
d'un côté lagardère a cédé son club
internet
de l'autre les allemands ont ouvert le
capital de leurs services en ligne dans
ce monde des services médias il n'est
même pas question d'argent
explications et yann fronty et bernard
ap
arnaud lagardère peut sourire il vient
de réaliser un très joli coup sans
débourser le moindre centime dans cette
opération personne n'a sorties d'argent
de son portefeuille il y a eu un troc un
échange d'actions
lagardère cède 99,9 pour cent de sa
filiale comme internet qui proposent des
abonnements sur le web aux français en
échange il reçoit six et demi pour cent
de tune line la broche internet de
l'allemande deutsche telekom
l'accord qui financièrement est assez
extraordinaire pour lagardère mais c'est
pas ça uniquement qui nous intéresse il
nous intéresse
on va en faire qu'on va tout concentrer
sur notre métier de base lié celui
d'être un éditeur et commerçants sur à
terme une transaction qui scelle le
mariage de deux savoir faire
tiens online est le premier fournisseur
d'accès sur internet en europe grâce un
club internet troisième fournisseur
d'accès français avec 320 milles abonnés
il pénètre un nouveau marché
mais si l'allemand est aujourd'hui prête
à acquérir une société qui perd de
l'argent
c'est parce qu'elle lui permet de
s'allier avec un géant des médias
lagardère propriétaire de radios de
chaînes de télévision ou encore de
journaux comme paris match et europe 1
l'allemand lui maîtrise la distribution
les filles c'est l'alliance du contenu
et du contenant qui demain alimenteront
le réseau mondial et l'enjeu est de
taille il s'agit de dominer le marché
européen du numérique et du multimédia
tout ce qui se passe sur internet semble
autoriser de belles fortunes et l'essor
d'activités commerciales le commerce
électronique ne cesse d'augmenter en
sept cent mille français aurait effectué
un achat via internet ce qui ne peut
qu'accroître la concurrence reportage
jean bernard schmidt et daniel vie
c'est l'un des personnages les plus
recherché de france
aujourd'hui tout le monde tente de le
séduire il a envie d'acheter
mais il ne veut pas se déplacer c'est le
cyberconsommateur son champ d'action
internet est là il a l'embarras du choix
comme par exemple se retrouver ici
dix mille mètres carrés d'hypermarchés
et phase 1 clients dans les rayons
toute la journée soixante personnes
prépare les commandes passées par
ordinateur et livré à domicile
les bois sont en général beaucoup de
produits pour bébés houra.fr et le
premier cybermarché lancé park aura un
groupe de distribution classique
histoire de s'adapter aux nouvelles
tendances déjà à 50 mille produits
disponibles dans les rayons virtuels et
150 mille visites en un mois seul
problème le site coûte très cher à
exploiter avant d'avoir notre premier
client on a dépensé plusieurs millions
francs pour développer l'entrepôt pour
faire de la publicité pour stocker et
aujourd'hui les coûts de livraison
coûte assez cher ne coûte plus cher que
ce qu'on gagne sur chaque client en
pariant sur une croissance continue le
site espère être rentable dans 4
si non plus on ne gagne pas encore
d'argent livre disque est joué ce
commerçant s'est développée uniquement
sur le net
4 millions de visiteurs l'an dernier des
clients potentiels qu'il faut convaincre
des points forts d'internet une autre
avantage par rapport à un public c'est
effectivement le fond de catalogue c'est
l'exhaustivité des bases de données et
de tout ce qu'on peut leur proposer
alors que dans le caza magasin
l'avantagent c'est plus effectivement
cette petite relation humaine compact
instauré avec inventeur alors pour
remplacer le vendeur ont multiplié les
articles et les explications tout faire
pour séduire le client et surtout bien
se placer les premiers à avoir mis les
magasins au bon endroit c'est à dire
dans la meilleur e commerçants sur les
meilleurs emplacements du centre ville
ces gens là où une prime par rapport aux
suivre sur internet c'est pareil si vous
y allez en premier vous avez les chances
d'habituer les clients à venir
fréquenter votre site
plutôt qu'un autre sur internet et c'est
un peu comme si vous aviez le meilleur
emplacement sur la place du centre ville
être les premiers ou lino v class points
comme par exemple rassemble le plus de
clients possible autour d'un produit
pour obtenir des rabais auprès des
fournisseurs des produits pour la beauté
des mains de manu à côté de clust
d'autres sites se lancent chaque jour
sur le même créneau à chacun son idée
géniale
qu'importe la rentabilité l'heure est à
l' enthousiasme encore faut-il fidéliser
l'internaute et c'est lui qui fera les
fortunes et les faillites de ce nouveau
commerce
voilà puis j'ajoute que france
télévisions va consacrer 200 millions de
francs sur les trois prochaines années
au développement de services interactifs
sur le cap sur la télévision par
satellite et numériques sur les réseaux
de téléphonie mobile et sur internet du
sport ce fut hier soir une soirée de
football particulière 12 but en deux
matches avec les victoires respectives
de marseille sur le psg et de nantes sur
lyon 12 but que nous avons rassemblés en
quelques poignées de secondes avec
l'expression de tous les sentiments des
vainqueurs et des vaincus commentaires
marque maison monde
l'orgueil pour marseille se faire battre
par pari impossible l'humiliation
n'était même pas imaginable et pourtant
cela commence mal christian la 7e minute
marque pour le psg
l'expulsion leroy tacle le roi jérôme de
l'om fait son métier sur leurs rangs du
psg
chacun s'énerve l arbitre va à
l'essentiel l'expulsion le sursaut
quatre bus en rafale perez couget
abardonado et maurice à la 77e minute
c'est gagné pour marseille a pâti des
lyonnais face à l'énergie des nantais en
un quart d'heure la paire était dans les
filets da rocha puis six bières ce qui
est à la huitième et dixième minute le
naufrage de lieux de vie nos marques et
marque encore
bernard lacombe observe l'unique but des
lyonnais mais vers elle n'épargne pas la
honte à son équipe
c'est l'entraîneur sylvie et lyon sont
sonny anderson meilleur buteur du
championnat
suspendu pour deux matches c'est
franchement moins bien
en rugby vaut si la composition du
quinze de france qui rencontrera
l'angleterre samedi au stade de france
et bien sûr en direct sur france 2
christophe la mise en étant absent c'est
alain penaud qui prend sa place pour ce
deuxième match du tournoi des six
nations des bleus sous la direction de
bernard laporte
j'ai une petite inquiétude pour
l'instant pour abdellatif benazzi
victime d'une contracture au mollet
droit mais il devrait pouvoir jouer
quand même de la musique avec le nouvel
album de youssou ndour qui sort la
semaine prochaine youssou ndour défunt
une identité africaine très forte dans
ses chansons comme dans les entretiens
qu'il accorde
il faut savoir si une véritable star et
pas seulement sur le continent africain
c'est pourtant chez lui à dakar au
sénégal qu'olivier d'ennezat et raymond
chapelât non retrouvées
l'enfant de la médina le quartier
populaire de dakar en visite parmi les
siens pour accomplir son devoir de
citoyen
je suis venu ici et ma carte pour
pouvoir voter faire un choix
les sénégalais fils petit fils de griot
youssou ndour est devenu star dès l'âge
de 12 ans mais a toujours refusé de
s'exiler
c'est sympa de se toucher de se parler
de se voir des petits mots comme ça
youssou ndour qui exhorte les jeunes à
rester au pays
meilleur moyen pour imposer leur culture
à l'étranger tout un programme
ils attendent beaucoup de choses de moi
mais je sais que si je suis président
ils vont manger des pierres
c'est sûr donc c'est pas mon truc je ne
pense pas que je peux faire quelque
chose mais par contre il peut participer
à
au développement de ce pays je peux
supporter en tout cas les vraies causes
de ce pays je sens plus social
le chanteur est un homme d'affaires
avisé qui investit depuis des années
dans le développement de la musique
locale et c'est à dakar dans son studio
que youssou ndour a enregistré
l'essentiel de son prochain album
allez
il
mais
on vient d'un pays sous développés où on
vient de quelque part ailleurs on veut
pas toucher le monde on peut toucher le
monde après sa partie de parer d'un pays
sous développés à partir d'un pays
développés aussi grâce à la musique
place à la musique parce que c'est la
première langue pour moi un nouveau
disque un mélange d'influencés des duos
avec peter gabriel et sting les toiles
de dakar est un artiste ou dans le coeur
et la musique balance entre deux mondes
voilà c'est le nouveau cd de houston de
offranvillais cheap times qui sortira
donc le 22 février prochain
j'arrive en la fin de cette émission je
vous rappelle l'adoption en conseil des
ministres du projet de loi sur la chasse
projet qui pourrait être débattu à
l'assemblée avant l'été mais déjà les
chasseurs font du lobbying pour amender
le texte de dominique voynet dans un
instant vous retrouver isabelle martinet
pour la météo et puis le film la petite
absente un film qui vient de remporter
le prix du public au festival de luchon
le scénariste de la petite absence et
didier colonnes de créateurs de l'instit
je vous recommande tout particulièrement
ce film c'est dans quelques minutes à
0.55 votre voix le dernier journal avec
thierry thuillier à demain 20h bonsoir